hey everybody welcome back to Jaeger on
today's episode is a little bit shorter
than usual but it's something that I
really wanted to show that I normally
don't really show in my videos and even
still in this case a lot of it has been
off-screen but I really want to delve
into planning more in general Jaeger
horn is a project which I blend a lot
more than I usually do but still I think
it's a topic that's very interesting to
talk about and actually show as well
hence why I'm also delving into a lot
more in cinematics for these shots to
really show what the planning of this
right looks like because the way that I
went about doing it mostly was between
this episode and the episode that are
recorded before this I spend some hours
actually using the terrain textures to
plot down where I wanted to build
certain things and where I wanted a
coastal layout to go and in that way I
kind of get an idea of how the course it
can run and personally I think this is
possibly the best way to plan your ride
I think this is also something that's
very personal it's very subjective like
if you even want to plan your right at
all or what kind of play style works
best for you but I find that for most
people especially for people who don't
want to take papers and sketch their
ideas or in general has difficulty
putting their ideas into real concepts
but come up with ideas all the time I
think it's I think putting them down in
throwing textures is something that's
quite easy and you can always do it and
very easily adjust it it's already in
there in game and it's something that
you can also really easily use as a
guideline yourself to get the rest of
your ride and all the scenery in and get
it all placed in a sense that it's all
exactly placed like you were imagining
it to be because that's where I think
it's the the extremely crucial part in
the creative process from getting that
vague abstract concept in your head
being turned into a real concrete ride
or Park in planet coaster so yeah I kind
of did base this on a few sketches that
I made on paper I actually did some
concept art for this ride which is not
actually that user usual the thing for
me to do
but it's something that I figured work
it's kind of for this ride since it's
very much focused on sight minds and on
the general appearance while not even
being that extravagant of a ride in
general but still I really wanted to
experiment with getting every single
detail knelt down on the map so that's
what I wanted to show off here now
without further ado let's get into the
time-lapse and actually show you how you
can pick up that very basic idea with
terrain textures and actually turn it
into reality and build your paths and
coasters over it so what I had to do in
much of this episode is work on the
tracks for the coaster itself and this
is also where I was very happy to
actually get this planning in it kind of
just works very well for a time lapse
coincidentally since I don't want my
time lapses to consist of me erasing my
mistakes and going trial and error on
everything that I do which is something
that happens quite a lot but I usually
have to try to remove it from time
lapses but in this case you already kind
of have a guideline in all of the
terrain textures so you already know
where to go
of course I did still have to kind of
remember where I want the the coaster
tracks to go higher in where I wanted to
go down and up and do different kinds of
elements and interactions but generally
I think a terrain texture layout like
this is a very good guideline to follow
and something that also makes the rest
of the process a lot easier once you've
got everything painted down and it's
also just really easy because you don't
really have to draw anything I mean like
I like I said I did make some sketches
but you probably don't want to see them
they're pretty bad and they were very
quickly made just because I had like a
flash of inspiration of what it would
look like and I had to translate my sort
of brain mental image into something on
paper very quickly since I kind of think
very visually in that sense but I'm
really bad at actually putting it into
paper and blended coasters too slow of a
medium for that so that kind of works
very quickly but in a similar sense you
know having having a layout like this
also prevents you from forgetting what
you were going for
place now something really awesome
happened in the time that I started
recording this episode unfortunately
most of this episode was still recorded
when that didn't happen yet but recently
planet coaster got an update and one of
my favorite things in that update was
the removal of terrain collision
detection now you were already able to
put coaster tracks into terrain and
scope the terrain around that which is
what I'm doing in this episode basically
but now you're also able to build a
coaster track first and then scope the
terrain out and I mean around that and
actually have the terrain go through the
coaster track which is something that I
wasn't able to do at the beginning or
how through 2/3 of this video so
unfortunately you're going to have to
see me struggle with getting the terrain
actually into the track or a lil bit
underneath the track if you will but
that's going to change maybe just a
little bit too late but it's still
really awesome Edition nonetheless now
you'll notice that a lot of the coaster
stays very close to the ground which is
quite difficult for a mine train of
course but in this case it's really
close to the ground there really isn't
much of a mountain for this coaster
except for the mountain which is really
the major weenie and one of the reasons
why I did that was because I really
wanted to keep in mind the photo points
if you will there are quite a few shots
where I always planning to have the
coaster station in the foreground or in
basically have the coaster track and the
little hills around here in the
foreground then having the station a
little bit after that and far in the
background having the whinny of the
church tower etc so basically everything
over here is very low to make sure that
the the sight lines from the coaster
itself really stay intact and it you can
see the mountain far away and then it
seems a bit bigger than it really is but
something that also kind of helps with
keeping everything very low here is that
I really was inspired by big grizzly
Runaway Mine Train especially its second
half where it's very fast and stays very
low to the ground as well so we've got
the second half of this coaster also
dropping down from that very steep drop
instantly underneath the path and
underneath some bridges and into some
pretty fast curves and even some airtime
moments I think it's a little bit of
slightly twist the airtime in there so
it's a slightly more exciting part of
the right than the first part the first
part being much more the sort of
mountainside very mellow quiet
train ride that's much more reminiscent
of Big Thunder Mountain I think in terms
of layouts but the second point is
really going to be that more rough
second faster more thrilling part of the
ride yeah hence why everything's also
kind of low and we've got though the
coaster sort of hugging those very small
hills with his curves and the hills that
the coaster has also I wanted to get
this small lake in here since before I
was actually planning to have a queue in
here but that was a part of planning
which turnout did not really work so
well because the initial idea was we
would have a queue in here just because
it would fill up quite nicely but the
thing was it kind of created more
bridges than I wanted to have and the
bridges kind of blocked the line of
sight pretty much everywhere and I
figured a lake which just creates a
better sort of photo moment for that
part there even though you don't really
have a part going there I think it is a
really good view for the coaster itself
especially since the coaster has two
curves that go beside that lake from
which on the other side of the lake
you'll be able to see this rich summer
in this elation I mean this is the sight
line that I was talking about a little
bit ago so hopefully that kind of adds
to the atmosphere of the ride oh and in
the middle here by the way I haven't
really talked about this yet but we've
got the transfer rank I wanted to make
this coaster as compact as possible and
you can probably tell it's actually on a
very small footprint it's actually
really small and in terms of the layout
on the larger scale how small is I was
more inspired by Seven Dwarfs Mine Train
I suppose
in a sense that this ride could be
placed even somewhere in the middle of a
park perhaps or somewhere along the edge
of the park on a very small footprint
where there really isn't too much space
left so it's all very types and also
tried to make the borders completely
straight and allow for some backstage
areas besides the coaster as well so
along with that thought I also wanted to
incorporate the transfer tracks in a way
that made the coaster more compact but
also didn't feel like I had to waste any
space to build things that you don't
want to see so instead I kind of opted
to have the transfer track in full view
of course I'm going to hide the actual
technical part of the transfer tracks
but I actually wanted to use that part
to add an extra building and have the
coaster go around the transfer track
like that which should hopefully make
the scenery a bit nicer it adds one more
building to add to the scenery and it
means it's both functional but it's also
an important part of the scenery and at
the same time it should make the coaster
a little bit more compact so yeah that's
kind of the plan behind having the
transfer rank and the wall the entire
storage building for the coaster stay in
the middle of the view like that and
with that the layout of the coaster is
also really mostly finished at the end
of it it really dips into a lower
section after diving alongside the lake
over there and after that it still has
one final curve and curving over the
lift hill which I thought was some
interesting interaction also with the
section after the second drop as well so
we've got that going on and then after
that it really loses all of its speed
and I'm pretty glad with that I don't
think there was any potential energy
wasted there so that's pretty good so
the thing that I wanted to move in
afterwards with the queue and I sort of
wanted to fit that into the footprint
which we have so far I'm still not
entirely sure but I'm most likely going
to just make this the pipe border and
get a building over the queue get some
scenery around it
such a sense that it's not obvious that
you're on the side of the cloak but it's
still fit in with the footprint of the
rest of the right so on that's what
we're going for here although of course
I also wanted to have a bit of
interaction with the ride itself so we
have that bridge going next to the
bridge then is the final pipe of the
coaster and we also have another bridge
going over another section of the
coaster I'm slightly worried that the
queue is a little bit too short because
quite honestly it really is so I might
see if there's a way to extend it next
to the station building but to be honest
I there's not too much that I can do
about it I guess I wish there was a way
to make more more tight kettle pens
because that would be something to
really help the capacity of the queue
but until then I'm going to keep it
mostly this way because it works better
in terms of the way that it looks I
didn't want to draw the queue into any
areas where I didn't want to have it so
my space was pretty limited there and in
a way I kind of backed myself into a
corner but we'll see at least I'm
somewhat glad with what we have but if
there's any way to improve it I'm
definitely open for all kinds of ideas
and I'll be sure to still mess around
with it so the rest of the path system
is also something that anyone to plan
since there are also quite a few photos
box especially for the part that I
wanted to keep in mind and also some
buildings as you'll notice and this is
actually something that's pretty crucial
to the planning's using textures as
you'll notice I'll have a color code for
certain things so the coaster track had
that one brownish color we had the light
not really sure what it is the light
hair color I think it was for the pots
and then we also have another Brown
earthy color for the buildings so you'll
see some buildings along the side sort
of poking off the backstage area and the
other side of the mountain and we also
have a play gray or brown spots for a
restaurant which we're going to have and
that is also definitely going to be a
bit of a photos box right there as well
it's going to be a restaurant which
probably has one of my favourite angles
of the
and also has a past coming out on the
other side which very tightly hug the
coaster as well which gives you another
unique view of the coast route it's
actually a part that doesn't go anywhere
but it will have a view point so I think
it's pretty justifying being there
nonetheless and yeah that's basically my
basic blending of paths and coasters a
lost little tidbit that I got into here
I was just making a quick wooden sense
as the border of this area right here
not actually too sure if I'm going to
keep that but I still kind of do like
the fence and it's simple little centers
like this that don't really take you out
of the out of the theme but at the same
time they're simple and realistic enough
to be in an actual theme park that I
really just like to build also there are
very small variations I think are pretty
crucial like with many of these things
be it buildings or offensives or
anything wooden structures that you're
building I think going back and just
slightly moving stuff it only takes a
few minutes but it makes it look so much
more realistic and slightly varied
anyway that's basically it for this
episode so I want to thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you guys in the
next episode in which I'll get back to
some proper steaming bye guys